hello everyone i'm alana and today i am
very excited actually um to sit down and
watch the halo the series official
trailer i guess it's on paramount plus
i didn't even really know that that
existed
but uh yeah obviously i'm a huge halo
fan um i have been my whole life and
this one's nuts to think about because
i swear the last time or the first time
sorry that we heard of the halo
tv series
was one of the early like don matric
original xbox one
conferences when they were like really
touting it being the all-in-one
entertainment system before they slowly
walked that back over time because they
realized that nobody wanted it so i'm
kind of amazed that it still exists um
it
seems to have taken longer to make than
a video game but yeah i i mean i've
always been excited about it i've liked
all the halo comics and books and the
already existing series so
i don't know hopefully it's good
hopefully it's good let's let's take a
look i'm watching this on
the paramount plus youtube channel let's
do it
watch 24 i feel like i didn't know that
probably should have
you
humanity's best weapon
master chief huh
the master chief was enhanced and
trained for one purpose
to win this war
he and the other spartans
are our only effective weapons against
the covenant
that's pretty cool that just 100 percent
look like the game though
what hugs you seeing the the vehicles is
getting me
but i feel like
it doesn't look like that live action
upgradeable
and most importantly
that was kind of cool controllable
covenant forces appear to be excavating
some kind of object
when i touched the object i felt
something
i felt different
what they did to us
that's right i just remembered i had
read this before that this is not
supposed to be canon so it's not
actually supposed to be like reflective
of the trilogy i'd forgotten about that
um
it's like an alternate
take on halo for some reason i don't
know why i feel like there's so much
rich halo law that already exists that
like some of the games didn't even
necessarily flush out that well that
you could do in a live action way like
even odst in a live action anyway we'll
get through the trail
thinks you know
and you just decided to help me why
wouldn't spartan do that
[Music]
what does one do with a super trouble
you're not sure you can trust
hello master chief
i'm cortana
my immediate reaction is that i hate
that
why though
that's not necessarily fair of me maybe
it's just because it's different why oh
my god
it's because she
no
it also looks weird like that looks like
a digitally altered face but if you're
gonna do a digitally altered face just
make a completely blue
again maybe it's just me being a fan and
being like it looks different i don't
know i could be overreacting but that is
my gut reaction i don't love this
master chief recovered something sacred
ring
halo
[Music]
humans
surrender to the covenant
cortana i'm gonna need you now
that was cool
win the war
okay
few things um
and it's it's so hard to like even try
to do this objectively because i don't
know if i'm doing it because i'm such a
halo fan like
maybe i shouldn't even try
um the things i liked
i definitely like the way the ships look
it's so cool seeing like
the ship's
live action i thought they looked really
good they don't look like they're
straight out of the game i guess the
covenant ship did the drop ship did
um
my biggest and most immediate complaint
is why would you not use halo music why
would you use a remix of another song
when you have a franchise that has like
some of the best music but i get that
maybe this trailer is supposed to be for
audiences who aren't just halo players i
don't know
this marketing team's probably like we
need to broaden but
why would you not use halo musically i
was waiting for it that whole time it's
such a weird choice um
second obvious talking point is
so it seems like
the
enemy is whoever this no cool i'm so bad
at this
whoever this is um a human
antagonist
is like
i guess the whole trailer comes across
as being very human-centric um with the
the girl that you know is like why would
you help me
you're a spartan earlier um
it does seem like like her this one like
there are a lot of like human
drama elements which halo has but i
don't think is like a huge selling point
so clearly that's a refocus maybe that's
for budget maybe that's trying to tell a
different story i do think the way that
like spartans relationships with with
other humans um i think that that's
interesting if it were more of an origin
story a little bit earlier because i
think the spartan
program is more interesting
um
so it's humans across the board clearly
i feel like choosing
to have your antagonist
be
a human who is like allied with the
covenant rather than just covenant
is very strange i'm curious to see what
other people think of this i've not seen
anybody else's
impressions but my reaction to that is
just like
why on earth
like i feel like that has to be a budget
thing or that they're like we need to
make it more realistic or like more
you know grounded but
the covenant is so cool
and like a such a rich part of the
universe
i don't know i guess i haven't seen it
but to me that's like
immediately pretty off-putting um but
i'm trying not to like jump to too many
conclusions i just don't i don't love
that um
it just seems so unnecessary but
i don't know maybe there is a good
reason for it maybe they're trying to do
something super different i never want
tv shows or media to be the exact same
as the games right um
[Music]
because then i would just know
everything and i would just go play the
games i prefer they'd be a little bit
different but
i think the thing that overall
made this whole thing a bit off-putting
to me and again i don't know if it's
just because i'm being a halo fan like a
little fanboy and i'm
too invested and i can't remove myself
from that um
but this feels like a more objective
claims and i just feel like it kind of
looks generic
um
this is sort of a cheap
i don't want to say that i'm sure it's
super expensive
it's just not
like i liked that because it it's like a
cool thing to see the live action but
even the
the way that they look
i don't know
it just looks kind of generic
sci-fi like that could be any other
sci-fi show to be fair it's just a
picture like this is
that kind of looks like a fan film
obviously the set has got to be very
expensive but like that's not a good
shot um
i'm just like not impressed with the
production value at all
i don't know i wonder if maybe this is
something that i need to like come back
in and watch because it says here it has
50 000 likes so i'm worried that i'm
like an outlier and everyone on youtube
could be very mad at me
it's happened before that i don't love
the way that this looks i don't know
maybe i'm being too harsh that just
doesn't look
i don't know man something's just off
about it like it
it looks a little bit generic
and it
something about the way it's shot just
doesn't
look
of the quality i would hope uh but i did
think that the kicking of the battle
rifle was [ __ ] cool
i thought that was pretty sick i mean
that's a nice shot
but i don't know what the plot is
suggesting with any of that i don't know
um
well i guess it has 3.8 million views
and 50 000 likes maybe it does have more
dislikes we just can't see it anymore so
let's take a look at some comments
billy cobb this was weird i get that
they're doing a different timeline but i
would much have preferred a retelling of
the original trilogy shame will most
likely never get that now and they're
really a human antagonist yeah getting
death note live-action vibes okay i'm
glad i'm not alone there um
i don't i don't know that i want a
retelling of the of the trilogy right
because
again i could just play the games i
would prefer they do something different
i don't want it the exact same thing and
i think that's also really limiting for
storytelling like why do that um
different timeline is also okay but i
just would have thought that they like
if i were to write the halo tv show that
i would look at the stuff that i feel
like halo does extremely well the stuff
that's like really rich and impressive
um
[Music]
and i would lean into that rather than
just like inventing new stuff but i'm
sure they have their reasons
personally i've always wanted a halo
movie or series it was entirely animated
there is an animated series um similar
to the quality of the cutscenes in halo
2 anniversary they are very good because
they can show the true weight and speed
of the spartans which isn't really
achievable with a live-action adaptation
maybe that's part of it maybe that's
part of why it looked wrong to me is
that seeing it in comparison to the
games is that the spartans just look
super
not superhuman they just look like very
average humans and maybe that's
something that
is kind of hard to look at potentially
animation would never do it justice nah
if they did like a show like castlevania
that would be sweet
a whole lot of issues okay i'm not alone
by the looks of it but maybe it's just
the comments i'm seeing here a lot of
issues but my biggest is the fact the
villain appears to be human with the
covenant one of the most important
themes in halo is humanity and its
ability to overcome tremendous odds so
placing a human villain in the covenant
really undercuts that that's probably
part of my problem with it yeah
um
but again they could just go with a
different theme and i'm okay with them
going with a different theme it's true
that a theme of halo is definitely like
leaning into humanity in the importance
of humanity but they could just be going
with a different theme that is okay it
doesn't have to stay the same in terms
of that
um
but i don't yeah i'm not i just think
the covenant's so cool and rich and
interesting that it like undercuts how
cool the covenant is and how rich that
law is if they
have a human there but again maybe maybe
it'll be interesting
not sure how i feel the atmosphere that
i'm getting from this trailer i feel
very comforted by the fact that everyone
is having the same reactions i was
really worried that people gonna be
furious at me when they watch this video
it's happened before i'm like ah people
are gonna hate me for this one um not
sure how i feel the atmosphere that i'm
getting from the cereal is off it looks
so clean and refined yeah it does look
quite clean typical sci-fi looking
nothing special you don't get the
feeling that people are getting
slaughtered by the billions the halo
landfill trailer for halo was gritty
immersive violent realistic with iconic
halo music in the background i thought
right in the hitler universe it felt
unique something like that is what i
expected this just feels like any other
old sci-fi cliche series i think i said
that
that it feels like super cliche which is
a massive bubba i don't really care that
the story is different it's a vastly
different medium and needs a different
approach strongly agree with that they
could have at least tried to make it
feel like halo we'll see how it turns
out i don't know if i feel like halo but
like feel
like more budget i don't know special
effects color grading cinematography
halo's vibrant interesting universe i
agree that this doesn't look like an
interesting universe which is such a
brutal thing to say i don't know um
i'm gonna leave it there and maybe i'll
rewatch it again after a little bit um
there were definitely like a few things
that i liked with the ships mostly but i
feel like
not not a huge fan of this trailer maybe
i'll feel a little bit different when i
can get past the fandom or read some
other impressions i'd love to to hear
from anyone who really liked it like let
me know why
i'm open to
thinking about it a little deeper than i
already have so yeah but for now
impressions are
didn't love it unfortunately